pensez vous que le public aime dany boon
dany boon pense que le public aime dany
boon mais mais mais pas autant que dany
boon ne sème fait dany boon et le jour
où le public chemra autant que dany boon
scène le public sera ce que c'est
qu'être dany boon pensez-vous de dany
boon l'homme dany boon pense que les
femmes ont beaucoup de chance que dany
boon soit un homme pour vous dany boon
est synonyme de quoi franchement je suis
dany boon est très déçue que thierry
ardisson pose cette question
pensez vous que dany boon sur le plus
grands comédiens français dany boon est
un grand comédien c'est vrai mais
n'étaient pas français il estimé ah oui
pensez que dany boon peut tout jouer
dany boon ne pourra jamais jouer dany
boon c'est beaucoup trop durs car il
faut être dany boon et en même temps
être dany boon et jouer dany boon c'est
impossible
dany boon a complètement défoncé est-ce
que vous pensez que dany boon laissera
une trace dans le cinéma français une
trace de pneu oui est ce que dany boon
espère avoir bientôt une vue à son nom
mais dany boon des attire ardisson
rentrer dany boon dans ton gps et tu
verras est ce que dany boon est lui
aussi une star au japon
dany boon est elle effectivement était
au japon récemment avec un certain alain
delon et les japonais disait tu veux
dire qui est cet homme à côté de dany
boon
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus